I was hoping we could start with some  insights into what you were thinking  during your isolation and what does that  do to a minute psychologically I almost  seemed very backward to you know cursors  he seemed a camera civilized  you get a lot of people here respect  your Lobby the work you do  while you do what you do it's who you  are kind of  we'll print that story when you get it  but we got to go with this novel on my  hair Russians  we're doing this for us  no Timeship  it's time Robbie it's time  you know how people look at us  what a lovely night  you deal with  I sleep  kind of cars and birds and Grameen crap  she wanted to connect with something